clear blue skies lost in a haze
and the once green forest of
southwestern turkey have been painted
black
the wildfire started on wednesday across
four locations in the province of
antalya
found by strong winds they quickly
spread to neighboring regions
but soon 26 provinces far
and wide began reporting similar fires
several people have been killed and
hundreds of others injured
thousands more have had to leave their
homes
the blaze spread through the highlands
and raged suddenly we had no chance to
flee
but when we were engulfed by flames we
had to run to the city of monavgart
then we came back to find the house like
this
more than 85 wildfires have broken out
since wednesday
74 of them are under control but the
coastal provinces of adana
osmania antalya mercin mulla and izmir
are still trying to put out flames we
are in manawgat which along with akseki
is ontalia's worst hit district
two firefighters have been killed during
operations here
while many people have been taken to
hospitals
at least 25 villages and districts are
evacuated
and another fire west in marmaris has
killed a 25 years old volunteer
who was trying to take drinking water to
the emergency crews
[Music]
the fires wiped out livestock in rural
areas as locals struggled to lead their
herds to safety
hundreds of homes have been destroyed or
heavily damaged
but the turkish foreign minister says
help is on the way
christmas
we'll start partial payments to our
citizens who have suffered damage to
their properties
we have begun transferring a total of
2.7 million dollars
from various institutions and ministries
for emergency needs
in antalya's manager district
although wildfires are common in
turkey's mediterranean
and asian regions during the dry summer
months authorities have yet to determine
the cause of these fires sabotage
we are considering the possibility of
sabotage and
any other sources of the fires starting
and we will carry out the investigation
to provide answers to this we will not
give up
until we have all the answers there are
concerns they may be a string of arson
attacks
targeting the heart of the turkish
tourism industry
the extent of the destruction will
become clear once the wildfires are
extinguished
but for those in the affected regions it
will likely take some
to recover and rebuild resources